a woman
has been groped
kind of
a woman is making me too allegations not
in hollywood not in washington
not even in
reality but in virtual reality in the
metaverse a beta tester of the virtual
reality simulation world of the
metaverse which is being pushed by
facebook which changed their name to
meta
basically just a video game that you
live in it's just living in the matrix
she has claimed that she was virtually
groped
uh in in this virtual world
she writes quote
sexual harassment is no joke on the
regular internet but being in virtual
reality adds another layer that makes
the event even more intense
not only was i groped last night but
there were other people there who
supported this behavior which made me
feel isolated in the plaza which is the
center of the virtual environment's
gathering space
a lot of concern i don't i don't i don't
have the article here
but
it's it's making headlines all over the
place and a lot of conservatives are
making fun of it because obviously she
was not
she was not groped
she was not groped because to be groped
means to have your body held onto and
this woman's body was probably sitting
in her bedroom
but her mind was in this virtual place
and that's where she was i actually
think she makes kind of a good point
i'm i'm really glad to read this story
and the outrage from the left about this
story
because it means that the the left is
admitting that there's something other
than our bodies
right the left is admitting that we have
a soul
because her body obviously wasn't groped
it was her her soul or her mind or some
other aspect of her person that's not
physical that was groped and i think
that's true because i don't think we're
just our bodies
i think you can be violated in a way
that is not corporeal
it's not the same it's not the same as
you know having some guy
pinch you as you walk by
but there is something to that
she's onto something
it actually does matter what you do on
the internet when you go onto the
internet i think a lot of people believe
that you go into fantasy world where the
rules of morality don't matter where
uh
social morals don't really matter you
can just do whatever you want and that
leads to really dark places obviously
you see that a lot with porn you can see
that with video games i guess this is
kind of a combination of the two but
really anything the way we talk to
people
the way the way we behave online does
have something to do with reality
because we're not just physical beings
we're also metaphysical beings
so i think i think it's fair so now what
what does that mean about this this real
world
means that we shouldn't just treat each
other like flesh and meat puppets
means we've got to recognize we do have
souls there is a moral order we've got
to respect that moral order even when
we're in these kind of strange virtual
environments and maybe we should avoid
divorcing our bodies from our souls
entirely maybe living in the metaverse
and plugging the brain stem into the
matrix which is probably what two years
around the corner i don't know i gotta
check in with alex jones he seems to
have a good track record these days
maybe that is uh not a great idea to
divorce those things maybe we need to
recognize we're body and soul we got to
live
we got to
behave as though both of those things
matter
not just
the you do you if feels good do it
materialism that the libs push sometimes
not just the gnostic
dualism that the transgenderists push
which is that the body doesn't matter at
all and it's just the metaphysical
reality is all that matters maybe maybe
both matter established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of lord or
lady in scotland just like me
your humble host lord michael knowles
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land and a certificate established
titles is a project based on an historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards
or lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you will receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land you can even get a
couple pack for you and your spouse or
loved one of unspecified distinction you
will be able to have land right next to
one another at one square foot and you
will both get to be called lord and lady
you can get this on your credit card on
your plane tickets you can even put it
on your dating profiles
established titles currently having a
massive holiday sale
on top of that sale you can get an
additional 10 off any purchase you make
with discount code knowles so click the
link below or go to establishtitles.com
knowles use promo code knowles to save
an extra 10
today
i'm so glad that you liked that clip
i want you to be exposed to the entire
show and you can do that when you
subscribe ring that bell
you will get the notifications if you
don't get them here you can go to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
type in the michael knowles show never
miss an episode we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]